MARTIN OMANDER: Hi, Fer.
FER OLIVEIRA: Hi, Martin.
MARTIN OMANDER: Fer, you
are a principal serverless
specialist.
I've heard that means that
you spend a lot of time
with businesses who are
moving to the cloud?
FER OLIVEIRA: I sure do.
MARTIN OMANDER: I'd love to hear
if they know about serverless,
and if so, what
their thoughts are.
FER OLIVEIRA: Happy to share.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN OMANDER:
All right, I really
enjoy building serverless
apps with Cloud Run.
But do engineering managers and
CTOs know what serverless is?
FER OLIVEIRA: Well, they
look at the bigger picture.
The development process
passes through several stages,
before software is delivered
to their customers.
They think about how
to make each step
cost-effective and predictable.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK,
that makes sense.
FER OLIVEIRA: Let's start with
the first step, provisioning.
It can be a lot of work
to set up all [INAUDIBLE]
machines needed for an
enterprise application.
And CTOs know that their bosses
get upset if they get it wrong.
If they overprovision, the
business is paying too much.
If they underprovision,
the application
doesn't run properly.
One way to make this step
easier and less risky
is to go serverless
with Cloud Run.
Cloud Run scales up
and down with traffic,
and setup is easy.
CTOs like that predictability.
MARTIN OMANDER: I can see that.
What about the second
step in your diagram?
As a developer, I
really enjoy that step.
FER OLIVEIRA: Many CTOs
and engineering managers
don't enjoy it as
much as you do.
For them, this step
is often a bottleneck.
It's hard for them to
find good developers
with the right skills--
coding ability, Kubernetes
experience, Linux operations,
et cetera.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah.
Well, that sounds hard.
I mean, I don't
know all that stuff.
FER OLIVEIRA: Right,
but there is a way
to streamline this step.
Instead of trying to find a
team of all-around developer
superstars, many CTOs focus on
picking a platform that makes
regular developers productive.
Serverless platforms
like Cloud Run help here.
Developers who know one or
two programming languages
can be productive.
They don't need to be
programmers and IT-operations
experts.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, good
to know that there's
a place for regular
developers in the world.
OK, what about the release step?
FER OLIVEIRA: In this step,
CTOs and engineering managers
are looking for
increased automation
to achieve faster
time to market.
One way to do this is to use
build packs instead of Docker.
These reduce the operational
burden on developers,
while supporting enterprise
operators who manage
apps at scale.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Yeah, I know Docker,
but I use build packs
all the time, anyway.
It means fewer moving
parts in my application.
FER OLIVEIRA: Right.
Build packs can
also make it easier
to meet security and compliance
requirements without developer
intervention.
With Cloud Run, you
can choose whether you
want to use Docker files
or build in build packs.
If you use build packs,
you can go straight
from source code to production.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK,
and then there's
the run step in your diagram.
FER OLIVEIRA:
Enterprise applications
are often complex and
hard to keep running.
CTOs know that the
business loses money
when the applications go down.
For example, they might
lose their ability
to talk to their
customers, to take orders,
to charge their customers.
Or their employees may be forced
to sit idle when enterprise
application goes down.
MARTIN OMANDER: Hm.
How do they prevent
those outages?
FER OLIVEIRA: CTOs
know that complexity
is the enemy in this step.
One way to reduce
complexity is to let
your cloud provider handle it.
Cloud Run does this
by abstracting away
the infrastructure.
And it's fully integrated
with cloud monitoring
and cloud logging for an
enhanced operator experience.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right, thank
you very much for sharing this
with us today, Fer.
And thank you,
everyone, for watching.
If you have questions
for me or Fer,
please add them in the comments.
Also, write in the
comments if you
have topics for other
serverless things
we should talk
about in the show.
Thank you for today.
[MUSIC PLAYING]